so if I could have any element I wanted
for Christmas I think I choose hassium
because I know nothing about it I made a
video about it and I'd really like to
see it to see if I was right what does
it look like what does it feel like what
color is it but I don't think I'll get
it at least this Christmas well let's go
I would say carbon because we all know
that diamonds are a girl's best friend
terbium score good name helium because
it makes you boys go hard
hey and fantastic elements very light to
mosun let's go to the oxygen
yeah well as of sustain live basically I
go for aluminium to cook my turkey
ciji have an answer for that but I don't
want to put it out for public
consumption yeah yeah I'd have to be
mercury a soccer play with it
I'll take Mary Mary it's a cool side of
it there were little footballs on the
desk that's how you play it I'll be
platinum like a frog it makes an
absolute fool to you man
beep Latin because it's the most
expensive element
probably neodymium because it can be
blue red or green which are all
Christmasy colors it depends on how
concentrated the solution is so you can
modify it that way
rubidium it's explosive so you know what
I'd really like for Christmas is a nice
big chunk of cesium that I could go and
drop into a perhaps a small bottle of
water and I'm in true fashion I don't
have to wait till Christmas because I'm
not gonna be here and am cuz this is
what I got this morning it's my
Christmas present it's five grams of the
finest caesium nicely but bottled up in
this little old ampule and as you can
see got my grubby mitts on it warmed it
up lovely liquid metal so what are we
gonna do with this metal in the new year
I wonder this dysprosium know it's got a
good name well I left boron so boron is
a really nice element to have but if I
was gonna go for a transition metal I
really like manganese it's not
particularly coloured but it's got some
really cool chemistry
[Music]
'i'm sorry sodium is nice and stable
relaxed nitrogen and because i do more
work using nitrogen it's in earth
atmosphere does not react with other
elements especially it gets rid of
oxygen that's a good one okay I'm gonna
go with gold me just because of what it
is doesn't oxidize doesn't discolor and
lasts forever
there we go magnesium because we share
initials what's your name
Mike Greenwood this is the first
Christmas that we've celebrated with our
periodic table of the videos and we
bring really thrilled by the number of
people that have contacted us have made
comments have made suggestions and I
hope in 2009 you will make even more
suggestions and that we can bring you
some really quite exciting chemistry